[Music]
thank you
we were gone for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
come on Drax seriously dude
it's been two years since you passed my
life I still can't believe it who is
sending me these texts I think I might
have feelings for someone I've never met
so your ideas for your next film I could
follow my childhood friend to marry a
stranger chosen by his parents
hello hello
[Music]
oh my God and I think we should all go
to Italy
[Music]
okay picture a cell phone and an email
machine all in one thing
what do you call it
it's called a Blackberry hmm try typing
with your thumbs
are you familiar with the concept of
hypnotics hypnotics heads up but I'm the
wrong man
where is she
I'm a killer
but I'm also a mother
[Music]
and I will die protecting her
I have created this life
filled it with worlds
now seems the time to break one
he's coming for you with everything
what's the plan Dom I'm not sure anymore
[Music]
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
the guy flew 13 hours to be here I'm not
gonna tell you that you can't see him or
something
foreign
[Music]
my parents are inviting us to the Summer
Place for the big Fourth of July weekend
I can't leave my father
this whole world is falling apart and
this is what's consuming you well you
know
[Music]
I love you
oh okay well never mind when I was 22 I
got involved with the Russian mafia
I did not speak Russian
all I knew how to say was
23 years ago you still the only thing my
father never cared about sorry they're
coming with me back to Russia
[Music]
oh